good morning good morning hello to all dear
listeners
today I want to speak in Italian even though I
don't speak Dante's language well but
I will try to explain how I managed to
learn Italian why and how I have
done lately in these weeks
to refresh and restore my level a little
of Italian well in the beginning
since I speak Spanish it was not very
difficult to learn Italian about 20
years ago I studied a
phone language course
I listened many many times to all the
chapters I read I studied the
grammar explanations I studied
well I read and I  it seems that I was able
to change my Spanish and not
almost Italian which allowed me to
communicate with people in Italy because
for
me Italian was above all to be able to
communicate in Italy because my wife
and I really like traveling in Italy it is
certain that  much more enjoyable if you can
speak the language because in italy not
all italians speak english
but no after this course  or also find
some books
books with explanation or with ist
lists of english vocabulary and i read
some things in italian literature and
other things more or less interesting by
hand i
could as they say concentrate on
italian but i did i always
did a  just before going to italy
but a few years ago I discovered the site
on the web the narrator is a
very well done audiobook site in fact I have
listened to many of these
audiobooks such as for example the
adventures of pinocchio narrated by
maurizio the narrator very very  well
done with the narrator who in italy gives
all the characters of the story no
so but after this i have everything i think
o from me 20 audio books in italian from the
narrator i promessi sposi also an
audio book by alberto moravia and i
also read some  books like this are
different even i found it said i
really like the story i read this
book which is not recognized but for me it
was very interesting because  it
allowed me to learn things about the
history of Italy after the
very creation of modern Italy and
up to the First World War
and all this helped me to always
improve my Italian every
time we were with my wife in Italy
i think it must be 5 6 times but i have
tried to speak but also i have studied
in the link with our tutors
i have read some things we have in
our library
but i have to say these last ten
years i have concentrated in the in
the russian language in the language  czech in
korean in portuguese in romanian
all this creates confusion so
every now and
then instead of saying things
use italian words
speak portuguese russian i don't know but
this is not a big one but not a big
problem the problem for me because i
think i always have  the impression that
studying other languages ​​even the languages
I'm not studying if they do better
so yes now I'm going I'm going to Italy
after every after pa  recchi young
I will speak to you better in Italian also from
I spoke before
and this time for a while to prepare some for
this video in Italian
I worked in the link or I read
according to the statistics we have in
lincoln eto'o 55 thousand words and this
means that I read  or listened
to the same amount of
words and and not only did
I study in the link I must also say that
I read I don't know 10 11 chapters of the
betrothed because because I have
the narrator's audio book so I read on the
veggiato words and phrases that not that
I want to save or get to know
better that I really didn't know but
at the same time I found
some podcasts of Rai Due on the internet, in
particular a podcast that is called
at eight in the evening it is a
very very interesting collection of podcasts on
different topics
history literature and  other things and in
particular I listened to a podcast on
Charlemagne which was very very
interesting I knew almost
nothing about
this character  gio and on frederick the
great of russia
on the emperor romane romans also and
that was the most interesting on the life
of vincent van gogh
therefore learning languages ​​therefore
therefore it is not only a way of
acquiring the possibility of communicating
with italians with lele  people not but
also a door that opens other
possibilities for example the possibility
of learning about not only elise
history is this
this nation of these this country and
also about other things because there is a point
of view on the life of the van goghs  an
italian point of view a certain
italian which is not the same which is a
una navas analysis des vins from an
american and maybe i wouldn't have
listened 20 episodes on the life of
vincent van gogh in english
but italian in italian yes so i guess
always that language learning
is something not only very good
for the mind nor that as they
say it is a wealth and a wealth
more and more more and more  ù the things
we learn that are a grave molin is
very useful well that's enough
yes you have questions please
dear listeners
I will try to answer goodbye and
hasta luego